Joining me on the show this week is
author,
speaker and Associate Director of the
Henry Jackson Society,
Douglas Murray.
I've been familiar with douglass work
for almost a year now.
His name kept popping up in my twitter
feed after the Charlie Hebdo shootings,
like last week's guest,
Ayaan Hirsi Ali Douglas has been a
relentless defender of free speech even
when it isn't popular to do so.
Part of my awakening about the
regressive left came around the same
time as Charlie Hebdo when I saw more
concerned for political correctness then
for the victims of the horrific attack.
I was really impressed with.
Douglas is clean and clear explanation
of why free speech must be protected at
all costs.
And that's one of the issues we're going
to talk about today.
This is where I should tell you the
Douglas Murray is a neo-con.
The word neo-con sounds kind of evil to
me.
Sorta like a decepticon.
Uh,
and like decepticons neocons are big on
world domination,
or are they.
Well,
that's where we're going to find out
when we talked to Douglas today.
You know,
we get so lost in throwing around labels
all the time that we hardly know what
they mean anymore.
As I understand that a neo-con is
someone who wants to spread democracy
through military intervention and we all
know how well that usually works out.
Right?
Uh,
well this is just generally thought of
in the American Lens,
but is it the same for the British?
I want to find that out.
Am I way off altogether?
I want to find that out too.
And that's what we're going to talk
about.
Some of you might be thinking,
Dave,
you've been labeling the regressive left
for weeks now.
How is that different than labeling
someone to neo-con?
I think the thing is here that we had to
identify what the regressive left stands
for us so that we could also identify
what we stand for.
As I've said before,
I felt the need to talk about the lunacy
on the left because there just weren't
enough voices amplifying the battle of
ideas that you guys all want to have.
That's why you're here.
And that's what I'm going to continue to
do.
So today,
as I sit here with someone firmly on the
right,
a scary neoconservative,
let's all have a battle of ideas and
actually listened to what he says and
then formulate opinions on those ideas.
Let's not do what the regressive left
does,
which is label someone and then prejudge
everything they say based on that very
label.
I think there's going to be agreement,
disagreement and everything in between
and it's our ability to have those
honest conversations and know that
people we disagree with can feel as just
an as principled as we do.
That's the spirit that I'll continue to
do this show in.
While I do want to continue having these
types of conversations,
I also want to assure you guys that
we're going to be widening the net
around here as well.
I want to talk politics,
science,
culture,
and more.
Of course,
free speech and the battle of ideas will
always be a mainstay,
but I don't want to become a one trick
pony either.
Next week I have two people who are
putting many of the ideas we've been
talking about into action,
David Keys and Faisal Al Mutar from
advancing human rights.org.
They're using the tools of democracy to
help advance human rights in parts of
the world where the people are most
effected by the ideas we've been talking
about.
The point is I'm going to keep mixing it
up,
keep letting me know what you guys think
and who you want me to talk to.
Most importantly,
let's keep pushing the conversation
forward so we can build bridges where
others were just tear them down.
Douglas Murray is an author,
a journalist,
and atheist,
a neoconservative and an outspoken
defender of free speech.
Douglas,
now that I've labeled you all sorts of
things,
welcome to the show.
Very nice to be with you.
I told you right before we started that,
you know,
we've only been doing this show for
about two months now,
but I,
you by far I've had more requests to
have you on then pretty much anyone else
because you seem you seem to be like
this sort of hub of free speech and free
thought and that even though I think
maybe we don't line up exactly
politically,
people wanted to see us sit down.
So I'm excited that you took a little
time here.
I look forward to hearing our
differences.
Alright,
so.
Alright.
So first what I want to start with is
the word neoconservative because it's
really the first thing that if someone
googles you that pops up that you were a
neoconservative or a neo con.
Now I know since I come from the left,
this is a real buzzword for my people.
They,
they freak out on this.
I think that you're some sort of
imperialist,
this kind of thing.
So first I thought,
well let's just get what the definition
of neoconservative ism is from you
first.
It's quite nice to know that's the first
thing that comes up on Google.
What I expected far words were basically
people have been moved from the left in
the postwar period in America and
famously described themselves.
Thanks.
So I've been crystal as being.
Liberals have been mugged by reality.
The truth is that now I wrote a,
I wrote a book on neo-cons about 10
years ago now.
And um,
the truth is,
is that the word neoconservatives with
ms.so
filled with pejorative connotations.
Everyone thinks they know what they mean
by that.
I,
I wrote a book partly to correct those
ms dot apprehensions.
I didn't think it was remotely
successful in that regard.
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
I'm,
I'm not that bothered about the term.
I think it is interesting and it remains
interesting,
the movement of people from a liberal
position as it were.
Um,
but apart from that,
I think has gotten relatively little
relevance today.
I think the word is probably noxious for
at least a generation,
right?
So I think within an American context,
it basically means using military force
to spread democracy.
Is that,
is that fair to say?
Um,
no.
I mean,
actually,
mainly no conservatives in America where
we're not interested in foreign policy.
The first,
first,
certainly a glitch weren't,
uh,
but,
certainly in recent years it's been
perceived.
I wouldn't say that in terms of bringing
democracy,
I think the most striking a
neoconservative foreign policy idea was
really that idea that you could use
military force for humanitarian means.
It partly solved a sort of imbroglio
that cut for a long time by that point,
which was that people on the left,
broadly speaking,
didn't believe in the use of force and
people on the right,
broadly speaking,
didn't think that humanitarian
catastrophes where the sort of thing you
use the military for neoconservatives
were few people to sort of meld these
things together and say actually,
as in the Balkans,
the use of military force to alleviate
human suffering and to prevent,
in that case even worse genocide
occurred was a good thing.
However,
I mean,
um,
as we all know the last 10 years,
if,
if it's possible for a neoconservative
to be a liberal who's been mugged by
reality,
then I think it's probably possible now
to be a neoconservatives who's been
mugged by reality as well.
So I guess this is why labels just suck
in general because I think what you're
saying is there's,
there's various lines through here that
you could be someone that does believe
in nation building and obviously there
are some people that do believe in
nation building and then you could be
someone that just purely believes on
intervening on Humira and humanitarian
regards and probably several other
things beneath that.
Right?
Absolutely.
I think that thing of that being a sort
of coalition with people from left and
right,
who certainly met I think in the
nineties over the Balkans mess again in
a bit and the early part of the last
decade,
but I think since that aligns that
occurred is suddenly gone and sold in
different ways.
Okay.
So that's.
I just wanted to start there just so
that people have a little bit of a sense
of the word and don't get too hung up on
it before all the commenters start
yelling at you right out of the gate.
Uh,
so I wanted to start also with that,
where I became familiar with you was
right after the Charlie Hebdo attacks in
France because you were all over the
media and I saw an interview.
Uh,
it was a discussion on Al Jazeera and
you were incredibly,
I thought lucid and clear and clean and
your explanation of why we can have no,
um,
we can have no give when it comes to
free speech.
So I thought you could possibly explain
that for me.
Yeah,
that wasn't the best interview I've ever
had.
One always tries to be polite of course,
but um,
it was a bit much,
but within 24 hours a of the 12 people
being shot dead in Paris,
the Algiers you inviting me on,
I wanted to have a discussion about what
this would mean about the,
uh,
allegedly nascent European hatred of
Islam and Muslims and,
and so on.
The,
the socal backlash thing,
um,
and uh,
I was fairly furious about that because
I thought that this was obviously
diverting attention from actual dead
bodies onto a potentially hurt opinions,
hurt feelings and so on.
And um,
anyhow,
I did actually,
it was a prerecorded for what it's worth
and I went back,
uh,
afterwards and said to a colleague or
they're never going to wear that
because,
um,
I think I did at some point give the
interviewer who was sitting in Doha a
piece of my mind about the fact that he
seemed to,
uh,
well he didn't like it,
let's say when I pointed out he lived in
an unfree country and was working for an
unfree media and that I wasn't
answerable to him.
I still haven't actually got the fee for
that interview
because
I'm not being asked back either.
I'm guessing the check is not coming in
the mail,
so I would just let that be.
So what I liked about that though is
that you clearly.
So yeah,
you called out the interviewer in Doha,
but really you were,
you were really calling out your own
media,
right?
You were calling up people in the UK and
you were calling out people in France
and probably in America and all over
these,
that sort of.
We were doing this to ourselves
literally before the bodies had been
buried.
Yes.
Well,
you know,
it's,
was recognizing in a way when you've
lost.
We've lost every round of the free
speech wars in recent years from the
satanic verses a fair on.
Whereas we always sort of get a
technical,
uh,
there's always,
there's always a technical way out.
We allow ourselves,
you know,
I mean,
I'm off the satanic verses,
you know,
thank goodness someone wished you
remained alive.
But,
but basically everybody has been.
Has this been often said,
internalize the fact why there's never
been another book.
Like the satanic verses published.
There probably won't be in our
lifetimes.
I'm off to Charlene Abdo.
You know,
people walked through the streets of
Paris world leaders in that sort of
preposterous parade through Paris.
Parisians holding up pencils as if this
was an act of defiance.
No inactive defiance would have been if
everyone had marched through Paris
holding a cartoon of Muhammad,
the act of defiance on the part of the
media that was so desperately trying to
find a way to be showing alliance with
they're slaughtered colleagues.
The best media could do is to sort of
repeat the same weasley excuses even
doing for 10 years since the Danish
cartoons,
the FA and try to save their dignity.
I mean,
it's a very undignified site.
I think the media,
uh,
after all we've got,
remember it probably awards itself more
awards than anyone else in the world.
Uh,
I know firemen and policemen don't,
don't,
don't have endless award ceremonies for
their bravery and give each other metals
and so on.
But journalists are doing it all the
time.
There is lots of journalistic bravery,
don't get me wrong,
but,
uh,
the reason why we keep on failing and
this is because actually our media as a
whole and most individuals just don't
want to make the kind of standard which
if we'd made it 20 years ago,
we wouldn't have to keep on going
through today.
Right.
And I suppose that's why people are
responding to you the way they're
responding to you and responding to what
we're doing because it seems,
it seems late at this point by us
talking about free speech.
It seems so late and overdue and I think
that's why there's been this,
this sort of groundswell of support for
what we're doing.
Do you agree with that?
I hope so.
I mean,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a bit pessimistic about the,
you know,
the possibility of another satanic
verses.
But look,
I mean,
things could change,
but it certainly seems to me that a lot
of people are increasingly aware of the
fact that we live in an age of
extraordinary caladis at an age of
cowardice that masquerades as an era of
truth telling.
Um,
you know,
I mean,
but these things are very confusing.
I think for most people when they're
living through them.
You know,
if,
if you just said,
if you just said I didn't know in 1999,
uh,
if I didn't see me,
you'd see me in one of us had said to
the other,
you know,
the 21st century is going to be racked
across the Western world with blasts for
me was you just thought you must be
drunk or I'm at the most.
If you believe that prediction,
you would have said,
well,
how do the Spanish inquisition come back
into Europe here?
How did that occur?
How did I know?
How did the Catholic Church remains
returned to medieval times and start
burning heretics?
Well,
no one would have thought that in 2015 a
newspaper offices across the world would
be debating whether they could show a
little cartoon or some guy just,
just,
just to not even have the,
I mean,
not even as it were,
accurate photo fit of Mohammed,
just anything which they then say could
be called Mohammed.
You wouldn't have believed that this
would be the thing that broke a,
um,
the western press,
but it.
But it is.
Yeah.
So was was one of the most infuriating
parts for you that actually what Charlie
Hebdo did was incredible satire,
making fun of all religions.
So I saw in that Aljazeera piece and in
another piece where people were saying
that this was racism,
what they were doing was racist,
but actually it was the reverse of
racism.
They were fighting for the principles
that the left is supposed to believe in.
Right?
W W,
w what?
Let's not forget the fact that we live
in an age when everyone not only has an
opinion but is expected to have an
opinion and most people therefore have
to mug up very fast on things they know
nothing about.
So after Shawnee Abdo and January,
a lot of people were just cropping up on
things who had always said he never
actually seen a copy of Charlene.
I've never actually,
uh,
read it or seen the cartoons or new
anything very much about it.
But one of the immediate attacks on the
dead journalists was of course to say
they were racist.
That was probably for me,
the thing which I have to keep going
during that period.
I thought it wasn't remain under the
belief that it was intolerable that a
group of people could go through the
front doors of the newspaper office in
Europe and gum people down with
Kalashnikovs and then for their fellow
travelers to,
as it were,
more pub afterwards by saying,
well,
they were kind of racist anyway.
I didn't know much about them until 24
hours ago,
but I'll say they're racist and then
nobody needs to mind.
I thought that was a real low point.
Yeah.
You know,
we've been calling them.
It's a,
it's a phrase that marginalized coined
the regressive left.
Uh,
and is that really where they have
failed us as a society more than
anything else by this meme that
everything is racist.
Everything is based in,
you know,
if you,
if you say anything you hate women or
you hate gays,
all of this,
this idea that people on the other side
that you disagree with can't be as
principled as you are.
Is that where the left has really
failed?
Oh,
you want me to just start with
describing why the left?
Then I'm going to push it and then I'm
going to put you on somebody.
Look,
the problem is several things.
Firstly,
just because people aren't religious
doesn't mean they don't still want to be
thought to be good by their
contemporaries and their peers.
And it used to be quite straightforward
to demonstrate how are you a good.
Well,
today we're sort of making it up on the
hoof,
you know,
I don't know.
Um,
we've got to be the most frenetically
supportive person ever of whatever the
latest rights issue,
but really the deepest,
uh,
um,
a desire of.
I wouldn't say it from the left,
it's just this,
whatever this movement is that being so
gripping in recent years to 70 people,
I think a predominant thing is,
is that people want other people to be
racist.
They want people to be racist.
They want Nazis.
They are fighting a war that was
effectively finished consummately 70
years ago and they don't seem to realize
it or they want to look as brave as the
people who fought narcissism,
but they can do it from their home on
skype or twitter or facebook.
And,
you know,
the,
these people are in so many ways
disappointed people because the number
of Nazis around these days is quite
small in number,
thankfully.
Uh,
um,
I mean there's a supply and demand
problem or there's an enormous demand
for Nazis,
but not much of a supply.
So people go scouring around,
uh,
the social media is media,
political landscape,
desperately trying to find people who
they can call Nazis or racists in order
to position themselves as therefore anti
racist or anti Nazi.
These people need this because they need
to feed off it and they're great hope is
that they can call everybody else racist
when and then be the only person
standing who's not a racist.
It's,
it's,
it's terrible.
I mean,
these people are not only fighting,
as I say,
uh,
I pretty much dead battle about they're
wasting their lives in the process.
Right?
So is that where the,
the meme of Islamophobia has come in and
been dealt with in such a dishonest way?
I'm going to guess that you wouldn't
argue that there's no people that hate
Muslims,
right?
You agree that some people just hate
Muslims,
right?
Sure.
And people hate all sorts of people.
Yeah,
sure.
People hate people because of their
color or their religion or whatever,
so their sexuality,
whatever.
But this idea of Islamophobia seems to
me that it's taken on this new thing
where you're not allowed to hate an
idea,
not people.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I think this is one of the most
successful ways that anyone's come up
with in recent years to shut down
debate.
It's no surprise that the people who
started off the I,
the term Islamophobia,
the people who were keenest on it from
the outset in the 19 nineties own words,
what were his limits?
Uh,
they wanted to portray themselves as the
only defenders of Islam against these
haters.
These people who hated all Muslims,
hated the religion.
It's been a trickle that's been going on
for a very long time.
Yeah.
We just,
just to clarify that the word came from
the Muslim Brotherhood,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think people realize that they
think it came from some think tank
probably in the United States.
No,
it,
it was just picked up by such people.
Um,
and I,
I think when a real problem because a,
still most people when they hear the
cry,
Islamophobia Think,
oh,
this must be a,
you know,
some racist problem and so on,
and the problem is among other things,
and it's scooped up any and all
criticism of anything to do with Islam.
And,
and that means that,
uh,
if you come out with a criticism of the
Muslim Brotherhood,
for instance,
the group,
which is eminently possible to criticize
a,
you are being Islamophobia.
Uh,
if you say you don't like something
which may well be very fundamental to
the Islamic faith,
you are being Islamophobic and that for
the time being,
and I think this will change and it may
change very fast and very nastily,
uh,
but for the time being,
Islamophobia trumps most other things.
So for instance,
um,
uh,
I,
you know,
you could be the,
you can be the most outspoken feminists
of your generation,
but if you said something that was
Islamophobia,
Islamophobia would,
for the time being trump,
feminism and so on,
gays by the way,
go really down low in this pecking
order.
No one really cares about that,
right?
Actually,
people seem afraid to talk about the
fact that isis is literally throwing
gays off the roofs of buildings.
There's no outrage over that,
right?
It should get it.
It should not be easier than this,
uh,
isis,
throw gays off buildings,
uh,
criticize isis and what's more,
criticize the ideology that they are
coming from.
I mean,
I,
isis poses an enormous problem because
Isis don't get their ideas from nowhere.
They didn't invent them yesterday.
They always publish along scriptural
explanations,
uh,
from the Koran and had he,
of why they're doing what they're doing.
Now,
that doesn't mean that people should say
isis through the gaze of the buildings.
Therefore,
all Muslims hate gays.
all gays or anyone else should hate
Muslims obviously.
No,
of course.
Yeah.
But obviously you have to identify where
the problem comes from and I mean,
you know,
I look around and I find ones of people
willing to do this,
uh,
at the moment,
you know,
and just a quick one,
the,
I mean,
you always get reached to the National
Union of students in Britain if you want
to reach for a bunch of idiots at the
National Union of students in Britain
recently,
didn't,
uh,
didn't condemn isis because they said
that it would be Islamophobic to do so.
So while Isis,
uh,
throwing gays off buildings and raping
young girls for the alleged crime of
being a Yazidi or occurred or from a
Muslim sect,
the,
a group,
men,
men have a rapist,
salacious.
Don't believe in it.
If you criticize that,
your Islamaphobic look,
as I say,
uh,
people are caught.
They're caught in this terrible,
terrible.
I'm a mess of half thinking a
nonthinking and um,
everyone's got to find a way to help
them think their way out of it.
But they've been to be quite fast.
They better be fast.
I fear that they're not.
So what would you say to the people that
would argue,
well,
we really created isis because we went
into Iraq,
which now by most accounts was the wrong
war to go into.
I'm not sure if you agree with that,
but uh,
and then by leaving so quickly the way
we did,
we just,
it was a breeding ground.
It was fertile ground for religious
extremism and all of this awfulness to
happen so that it's not just about
religion,
it's also about the geopolitics.
Can I make a point which doesn't always
go down well with American audiences,
but I think he's worth pointing out as
an outsider,
as a question because part of the
American thought disease on this is now
in Europe as well,
but it started with you.
We give you some bad ideas and you'd
give us as well this,
this American,
um,
self obsession.
This American idea that nothing in the
world can get screwed up unless it's
because of America is a,
an intellectual disease.
You've got to get over the world can go
to hell without America doing anything.
The world can go to hell without America
lifting a finger.
But every time anything in the world
does go to hell,
Americans ask themselves,
what is it we did or didn't do that made
this happen?
That's why you still see the amazing,
uh,
an example of not only the president of
the United States,
but other senior figures in American
politics even wanting to apologize for,
you know,
the era of the Crusades.
I'm sorry,
this stuff happened centuries before,
uh,
before the British even discovered,
um,
uh,
the early cities of America and so on.
I mean,
you know,
this,
this happened before,
before the US was,
was founded.
Uh,
you keep blaming yourself for things
before the creation of America.
And nobody is fooled apart from you.
I had a friend some years ago who went
to interview Yasser Arafat and Iranian
friend,
a journalist,
very distinguished journalists from
Iran.
And he went to interview,
yes or I for some years ago.
And he said,
I'm at the end of the interview.
Uh,
it was a knock on the door.
And one of you asked about how fast
goons or porthole or male friends or
whoever,
I'm said,
Chairman Arafat,
the American delegation is here to see
you.
And uh,
and my friend thought he had a scoop and
he said to,
I don't know who is this American
delegation?
And there was a delegation that's come
from the US to apologize for the
Crusades.
And Arafat burst out laughing.
Everybody laughs at this apart from you.
Uh,
um,
isis was not created because of George W
Bush,
uh,
um,
al Qaeda wasn't created because of Bill
Clinton or George Hw Bush.
There are things that America can do
well and things that can American can do
badly.
And there are things you've done that
haven't held.
There were things that Britain has done
that hasn't helped,
but it is not all because of you.
Right?
So I,
I do agree we have a way of making
everything about ourselves.
Maybe it's because we're a young
democracy and a lot of respect.
So we're still in our infant tile phase
perhaps.
Do you guys not have that in England?
Because obviously England has done all
sorts of imperial things,
far more far,
far richer history of materialism than
the United States saying you guys,
you guys don't have that feeling is that
it doesn't exist at all.
Britain,
Britain could teach America something
about imperialism and it can teach and
he could teach America something about
post and pivot as we've been going
through.
We've been going through this for
decades and rightly so.
I mean,
you know,
Britain,
like all countries are after their
height.
It looks over what it's done and wonders
whether it was a force for good or ill
in the world.
And we have periods where we are.
We seem to think we did no good.
And other times when,
when we realize actually that on
balance,
maybe things were better than that.
Maybe.
Maybe we did more good than we did harm.
It's always in the balance that goes up
and down and perhaps so it should.
But the fascinating thing to me again
about this is it's so one sided.
I mean,
you know,
we hear all the time about what empires
do and about the British empire and
about the mandate in Palestine and about
America is really quite minimal
involvement or at least quite brief
involvement to date in the Middle East
and so on.
But you know,
why don't we ever talk about Turkey?
Why don't we ever talk to them.
One of the most important,
the longest and largest empires in human
history was the Ottoman Empire.
I never hear anyone from America or
Britain or anyone else saying,
you know,
the Turks have got so much to answer
for.
Nobody ever says the Turks have done so
much wrong in the Middle East and until
we punish them sufficiently,
you wouldn't hear this.
It's only people in America and Britain
and the rest of the west who so self
obsessed and I know so little history
and,
and what,
what we think is we will be able to
solve it if we beat ourselves up and we
could beat ourselves up for every year
we have in the future and it still
wouldn't solve the problems in the
Middle East.
It wouldn't solve Iraq,
it wouldn't so serious.
Wouldn't solve Turkey,
wouldn't stop Isis.
It wouldn't do anything.
It's a luxury.
It's a luxury that I think is a kind of
decadent luxury.
I don't,
I don't approve of it.
You may have,
may have gotten,
but I think I got that idea.
So it sounds almost like a sort of like,
you see this as like a disease of the
Western mind sort of that we've,
our,
our society because of our freedoms has
moved so far past some of these other
places that we turn everything on
ourselves.
We don't realize sort of how good we
have it or something to that.
Well,
and also it's laziness.
It's laziness masquerading as moral
sophistication.
You know,
if,
if you go to a dinner party,
I mean,
I know you went at a,
I mean this is,
this is squared for you there,
but if you were to go to a dinner party
and somebody was going to see them about
Afghanistan and you wanted to say
something really clever about
Afghanistan,
you would probably say something about
how terrible American involvement in
Afghanistan has been.
Uh,
uh,
if you signed to any other power other
than a western powers involvement in
Afghanistan,
uh,
um,
it's not so sophisticated,
you know,
uh,
if you go from America or you go for
Britain,
you go for yourself,
you know,
you,
you look like,
you know,
something about African history,
which let's face it,
very few people do.
You start to look like,
you know,
about African history and you also look
like you're so morally sophisticated
that you can even beat up on yourself.
And what it means among other things is
you don't actually have to pay attention
to the world.
You don't have to go anywhere,
you don't have to really think about
things.
You don't really have to keep up to date
because every time anything happens you
can say,
well,
there was that time and you know,
and,
uh,
in,
and just come up with some date and uh,
and hey,
presto,
you walk away looking like you know
something and looking like you're
someone.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny,
I never thought of it sort of through
the prism that you're presenting it
right now,
but I think Turkey is a really
interesting example of this because if
I'm not mistaken,
since 1974,
Turkey's been in occupation of half of
Cypress,
right?
Isn't that,
isn't this an occupation of a sovereign
nation?
You still have one of my most salient
important points I should have gotten.
Okay.
You all right?
So I just tossed it up for you.
Take it away.
I mean,
Cypress is,
is the most startling example of all,
you know,
Turkey is a member of NATO and there's
an occupation of part of a European
country.
Uh,
and I never hear anyone talking about
this.
I mean,
you know,
unless you have Cypriot friends,
no one ever raises Cyprus at dinner.
Uh,
whenever anyone's got a placard on the
street marching up and down and in the
occupation,
they never talking about Cypress.
No one ever raises it.
Uh,
why?
Because they don't care and they don't
know.
And I'm,
I know I'm in it.
It's these things.
You can only point these things out and
hope that over time that trickle down to
this information gets somewhere,
you know,
but as I say,
in the meantime,
people have got a very narrow set of
facts and the easiest way out is to
think it's our fault.
Alright,
so I want to delve a little more into,
into Israel and Palestine and the
imperialism and how it all happen and
right.
People never talked that.
It all started with the Ottoman empire
and then the British empire and the
mandate and all that stuff.
But before we get to that,
let's just do a little bit quick on,
on Syria right now because it seems to
me by every estimation,
it's no longer a country under any,
under any circumstances that we consider
a functioning country.
Um,
and it seems to me that we're at this
point also basically just in a proxy war
with the United States pretty much in a
proxy war with Russia.
And my completely oversimplifying it at
this point.
Well No,
it's not quite approximate war with
Russia.
It's something else.
The truth is,
is that Syria is the end of Syria,
the end game in this area as it were,
which I think we probably are in now,
is the end game that aside,
and the Iranians always wanted,
which is assigned against Isis,
um,
because if it's a sad against Isis,
they know that the world will not back
Isis.
And you know,
earlier this year I started,
was interviewed by Jeremy Button at the
BBC and said,
uh,
you know,
talks about the opposition as these
terrorists of Isis and,
you know,
some years ago,
he wouldn't have been able to get away
with that so much.
She still can't completely get away with
that line now,
but some years ago,
he certainly couldn't.
I knew and worked with some members of
Syrian opposition more than 15 years
ago,
I think to begin with and know and knew
that there were people who were very
good,
who wanted their country not to be run
by the Bashar Al Assad family forever
and wanted Syria to be the great country
it could be.
Um,
uh,
all of our hopes have gone.
Most of those people are dead now.
And side has got what he wanted and the
Iranians have got what they wanted.
No one will bag isis,
quite rightly so in the end,
will allow us to remain in power a look.
This is to some extent,
um,
uh,
what happened is when we don't take any
interest and don't really get involved,
I,
I've always been against us intervening
in any major way in Syria for one reason
in particular,
which was that I always said that,
uh,
after Iraq and Afghanistan,
we should realize that we clearly don't
have the desire,
the willpower or produce the people
anymore in your country or mine who want
to spend,
you know,
20 or 30 years in this country governing
bits of it,
helping with infrastructure problems,
with anything else.
We're good at going in and doing the
first phase.
But we're no good at the follow up and
we should realize that.
And in the meantime,
uh,
not be responsible for any country's
collapsed.
The WHO's who's nation building
afterwards,
we really don't want to do.
So you're not a very good
neoconservative that I think because
wouldn't,
because wouldn't all the people that are
going to label you neoconservative would
say you should be for all these things.
Will it be,
will he do the labels never listened to
to actually say,
uh,
so what,
what should we do then?
Basically,
I mean without,
without really belaboring Syria,
because I know we could talk about it
for two hours.
I mean,
at this point watching this country just
collapse and Russia filled the vacuum.
What should the role of the West v?
I don't think we have much of a role now
as I say,
oh,
the,
the opportunity for,
for backing would go guys,
the window closed very early in the
conflict.
Um,
the truth is,
is that the future of Syria is not going
to be an American hands.
It probably never was.
It's certainly not and never was going
to be in British hands.
Iran will win in Syria.
Russia will win in Syria.
Bashar Al Assad will win in Syria and
everyone else,
including most of the Syrian people
lose.
And that's the end game.
That's the result.
How much would you like it or not like
it,
but that's the result.
Yeah.
I mean,
I basically agree with you on that.
How much of this do you think is that
it's very obvious that,
that Obama just wanted out of this part
of the world.
He just simply wanted out and the way we
left Iraq and everything else I was
against,
I was against,
that's going into Libya was against
this,
Syria,
all of this stuff.
But to your earlier point,
it seems like even if we do something,
everyone hates us and if we don't do
anything,
everyone hates us.
Is that the ultimate irony here?
Well,
it's an irony.
There are many others as well,
but,
uh,
yes,
I mean it is true that when America
rack,
so it gets blamed on when it doesn't act
to get blamed and sometimes that blame
is,
um,
is worth listening to and sometimes it
isn't.
I mean,
to some extent and how you have to
listen to who it comes from.
I would say,
um,
uh,
when people who criticize America or her
allies or country like Britain do,
so,
uh,
as helpful critiques,
you can usually tell and when people
criticize America or Britain or any
other country and they're speaking as
enemies,
you can also tend to tell,
um,
uh,
so you know,
that there are lots of things that we
can learn from this period.
I would think it would be very
regrettable if America decided that the
response to all of this will be the
America will decide,
well,
we,
no one ever loved us anyway.
So we're going home.
You know,
you wouldn't have America to kick around
anymore.
Sort of lap is a Jeb Bush like line.
And I,
I hope that,
I hope that America doesn't take that
view,
but you know,
Obama as,
as I hope everyone also learns the
lesson of Obama on this.
I mean,
bomb his predecessor and he found all
sorts of ways,
uh,
to mark up the Middle East,
but Obama has as well how many new ways
in,
in some ways,
uh,
you know,
a bomb was meant to be the president
who,
who brought the troops home and brought
peace in the Middle East and um,
you know,
he did a bit of that,
but he certainly hasn't brought peace
anymore than the waters receded and all
that other stuff.
And it's been a very,
it,
I think the Obama presidency,
the end of it,
people will realize not that his
predecessors were terrific and that he
wasn't or anything but that,
but the,
but the noblest aspirations,
uh,
it can all go wrong in wholly different
ways.
Doesn't that Egypt speech,
the speech he gave in Cairo,
which really was the reset,
doesn't that seem like not just a
different time,
it almost feels like it was from a
different planet at this point.
Right.
As,
as,
as did the Russia reset and as does the
Russia reset now,
you know,
after 9:11,
uh,
I'm a Dick Armitage.
A famously said to the Pakistani
ambassador who was saying,
you know,
uh,
oh wait,
no new usual guff about,
you know,
when an Isi and so on,
don't know who we know about our cage
and all this sort of stuff.
Dig On.
A teacher said to a bang the table and
when the Pakistani ambassador said,
you know,
there's a lot of history and you said to
bang the table and say,
history stops today.
It's a very noble a,
a threat.
But it's never true.
Um,
history didn't start a,
uh,
nine slash 11.
It didn't start with the beginning of
the first Obama administration.
I,
I wish we were wiser about this anyhow.
Well,
I think in a world of twitter and vine
and short videos,
our attention span just is afraid to the
point that people just forget history.
People just don't really care about
history.
So one more quick thing on Syria and
then we'll move on.
The refugee situation in Europe,
which I'm seeing these videos every day
coming out of all sorts of different you
from Denmark and Sweden and Germany.
Just,
it sounds like an absolutely terrible
situation.
And what I think is most interesting
about it is nobody had heard about any
of it a month ago.
I mean,
it basically started a month,
maybe five,
six weeks ago,
something like that before that it
seemed like there was no refugee crisis
and now it seems like an epic refugee
crisis.
Um,
well,
I don't know.
It looks at that from that.
That's at least what we were getting
mainstream here.
Well,
in Britain and of course you have,
I mean certainly southern job,
it's been going on for a very long time.
Obviously a and southern Europeans,
the Italians and the Greeks in
particular and asking for help for a
very long time.
And if you go,
as I did,
I'm a producer in south of Italy.
It's nearer to Libya than it is to
anything else in it.
Thinking Sicily,
uh,
you didn't see the graves of,
of migrants who tried to get over going
back 15 years or more.
Um,
so it,
it is quite long developing story.
It's true that every year in recent
years when you get towards the summer
months,
there's a surge.
Obviously it's easier to cross the
waters during those months.
This is a,
by the way,
I mean,
this is such a hugely complex story and
it's one that really,
uh,
we're all getting wrong.
It's a classic example of the sort of
twitter age not being,
not being really fit for purpose,
uh,
because this is one of the most
extraordinary and vast and migrations
that we've seen and it's being
misunderstood by almost everybody.
The majority of the migrants who are
coming into Europe and not from Syria
for the Syrians comprise of a minority
of the migrants.
You can pick your presenters,
some people think is a narrow and 20
percent some people up to 40.
It varies obviously between the points
of entry.
Um,
but,
uh,
the vast majority are coming from all
over the world.
So people from Bangladesh,
people from coming from a,
um,
the farther east than that,
there are people.
The majority,
I would think by my mo,
my own observation,
uh,
coming from a sub Sahara in Africa.
And so when you hear statesman a saying
and pundits and others saying,
well,
you know,
we need to solve Syria for instance,
and then we'll solve the migrant crisis.
These people don't know what they're
talking about,
even if it was in America or Britain or
any other countries,
gift to solve the humanitarian
catastrophe of Syria that would only
solve a part of the migraine crises.
Yeah.
What's your plan for Eritrea?
Has Anyone got one?
Has Anyone fortive one?
Can anyone point to Eritrea or on a map?
Uh,
uh,
we are so not fit for purpose in rising
to this challenge.
And all that can happen.
I don't know if you having to lower the
tone somewhat.
Benedict cumberbatch,
uh,
one of my compatriots was on stage in
London the other night,
finished a performance of hamlet and
berated the crowd and berated British
politicians for not bringing in enough
people.
That is the clever,
a caring thing to say at the moment.
We must open our doors.
Refugees welcome.
You know what?
In the UK,
a recent poll showed only seven percent
of the British people wanted immigration
into the UK to increase seven percent.
It's the same across Europe.
People don't mind accepting genuine
refugees,
but no one knows what to do with a
number of refugees,
genuine refugees who are coming and
absolutely nobody knows,
including Chancellor Merkel who having
saved Europe,
uh,
in the financial crisis has now totally
floundered on the refugee crisis.
And Angela Merkel doesn't know what to
do.
The European Commission just recently
tried to force quotas on European
countries to take migrants they couldn't
and didn't want to take.
And as the European Commission issued
that they admitted that that number they
were talking about was not fit for
purpose because the number was so much
higher.
What I'm trying to convey,
this is a continent wide catastrophe,
which we are at the beginning of.
And I think,
uh,
as I say,
we haven't even begun to rise to it and
we're going to see,
I think terrible things.
A winter's coming.
Uh,
uh,
Sweden is now putting refugees intense
because it's run out of properties.
Sweden took the view.
Let's let,
let,
let's show the world how generous we
are.
Let's be,
they said a humanitarian superpower.
Now they're going to have to raise
taxes.
They've got increasing public opinion
against them and the top party in the
polls in Sweden,
the humanitarian,
uh,
um,
hyper power of Sweden is the party of
the January called far right now,
top of the polls in Sweden.
And we're going to see that everywhere.
Yeah.
Is that,
is that what's coming next?
Because that is what I feared that I
think somebody like Bender Benedict
Cumberbatch,
I think there's some well intended
intentioned humanistic thing going on
here.
Uh,
well I don't know about that actually.
I mean maybe,
maybe they just want to look like
they're doing that,
but,
but if you,
you know,
it comes back to a really a core mistake
or error.
If you want to be generous,
be generous,
but don't demand other people to be
generous for you.
Uh,
the head of the Scottish nationalist
party a little while ago since she would
be willing to take in a Syrian family.
It's months since she said that.
And as far as I know,
there are no Syrians living with her.
Uh,
one of the top members of the Labour
party said the same thing months ago.
So far as I know,
she hasn't got a Syrian family in her
house.
Um,
I think this is posturing and it really,
it's not sincere because if you said to
those people,
look for numbers that are actually
coming and look at the numbers of people
who say they want to come,
you will realize that it is not only
economically but societaly
unsustainable.
So you would have to realize that
yeah.
So under the best of circumstances,
bringing these people in would be
extremely difficult.
And basically what you're saying is
we're doing this or this is being done
under the worst of circumstances because
there's just simply no controls here.
Well,
there's no good.
Doesn't nobody knows who's coming.
Most people destroy their papers before
they get here.
Most people pretend to be a,
a Syrians,
even when they're very obviously not.
Um,
and,
and the truth is,
as I've seen in covering this story in
the south of Europe,
the truth is,
is that once you're in European waters,
your,
your in Europe and you never,
you never go back.
There is no,
uh,
there's no particularly good way.
Even when this was a low point,
there was no particularly sophisticated
way to work out who was,
who and to work out who was genuine,
who was an economic migrant and that's
whole system is basically broken down
now.
So once you're in,
you're in and uh,
um,
I think this is going to,
it's going to obviously approve a
potentially breaking challenge for
Europe because these are,
uh,
the owner,
Germany is meant to be bringing one
percent of its population in addition
every year for the foreseeable future.
Who pays for that?
Who Pays for those people?
I mean,
you know,
I'm not heartless about this.
I would like to see everywhere genuine
refugees get asylum in countries,
hopefully return to their countries and
help rebuild them when they're safe
again.
But I would like genuine asylum seekers
to get assigned.
But the moment,
the whole thing is so tied up that
actually I think Europe's heart is going
to harden towards all of these people
and in that lack of attention to the
detail,
I think yes,
across Europe we see a catastrophe
starting.
Yeah.
What do you make of the Gulf countries?
You know,
Kuwait,
Bahrain,
united,
Arab Emirates,
etc.
I read this morning that the six main
gulf countries have taken in zero
refugees.
These are theIr brothers,
are they not?
I mean,
what,
what's going on here,
brothers?
In the same way that the,
uh,
palestinians have their brothers.
We'll get to that next.
Uh,
um,
well,
look at the gulf state countries
bringing no syrian refugees.
And one,
one kuwaiti official,
uh,
rina recent interview was asked why and
said,
I'm a,
an interview in arabic.
It's on the net.
Uh,
said,
uh,
that the reason was because a qa,
you have to understand,
he said that we are very fragile island
countries.
We are,
we can't take in all these people.
They are traumatized.
They come from a different culture.
You know,
it's a different culture.
Syria,
we can't put up with them in the gulf as
much more like Sweden.
Why don't you go to Norway,
Sweden,
uh,
um,
and so now,
and you see,
it's another thing of people's good
instincts being used against the
european is here.
I don't hear that.
What european see is catastrophe,
what did we do?
We must be responsible.
What's our responsibility?
We must do this.
We must do it even if it breaks us and,
and over in the gulf,
taking in zero people and they don't
give a damn about it.
And frankly I think they probably find
it quite funny that the europeans have
fallen for the idea that this whole
catastrophe,
it's the fault of the europeans.
Yeah.
Alright.
So I do want to move on,
but I have to backup for a second.
So what are you thinking in the mind of
someone like angela merkel?
What do you think?
She's actually thinking.
She has to know that it's not
sustainable.
Right.
And I get it.
She's either trying to have these lofty
goals of trying to do something on
humanitarian grounds or whatever.
What do you think really is going on in
her head?
Also knowing that,
as you said before,
this probably is going to strengthen the
far right in Germany.
Yeah.
I mean it,
uh,
Germany,
it may,
it may not actually be possible to solve
it because in Germany for all sorts of
obvious historical reasons,
uh,
if you,
if you say,
if you say in britain,
uh,
I don't know,
we might have a migration so large that
a british culture,
but it's a cycle basically over.
If you were to say that if you've always
not true at the moment,
but I mean if somewhere down the road
you were to say that you,
you would still get most british people
sort of thing that,
you know,
we're nice guy.
We enjoying ourselves a country where
we've been broadly a force for good in
the world.
They wouldn't want britain to be over.
Germany has a different thing.
There are a lot of people in Germany,
a who for historical reasons and some
understandable historical reasons.
Basically think that german guilt can
never be alleviated and the anything
other than the destruction of Germany
could never,
never rid Germany of its sins.
Now,
my own view is that those people may be
in the years ahead themselves in a
minority.
I think it's quite hard to tell young
germans that because of something their
grandparents did,
they have to abolish themselves as a
country or as a society,
but they've definitely got the problem
harder nicely.
You can see that in angela merkel's
response angle America when she was
asked recently at the press conference
by nice german lady who just sort of
said,
you know,
isn't this,
isn't this a problem for our country?
And I am concerned for my country.
I was just brushed off by anglo marco as
if this woman was some wacko weirdo.
It who'd come from recess deville.
And you see this all throughout.
Let me give you one other very quick
example of their least paquita protests,
which I don't aGree with.
I'm,
I'm concerned about them.
Uh,
but I think that they are,
there are all sorts of things.
They are obviously an anti islam
protests.
They will spend 90 migration process and
all sorts of other things,
but it's a legitimate,
uh,
I'm used to be with time as legitimate
political grievance and needs to,
needs to have an eric angle,
merkel users her new year message to say
that the piggy to protesters have a
coldness in their hearts if instead of
that she had said the islamists who the
buggy to protests are mainly concerned
about have coldness in their hearts and
we as germans must be careful not in
response to this hatred to become
hateful ourselves.
Then that might be something.
But because he,
angela merkel's problem is she can only
deal with secondary problems.
She can't deal with the primary ones.
Very,
very.
I said that will be a final,
final,
final point.
I don't know if you saw it,
but the other week a fascinating thing
happened at the un in New York angle.
Merkel was sitting next to mark
zuckerberg for lunch and,
uh,
unfortunately,
angela merkel's microphone was hot.
Everyone in politics and how the hot mic
moment,
but how mike was still on it.
Possibly the worst moment of could have
been.
I'm amazed it hasn't been picked up
more,
but she sat down to lunch beside mark
zuckerberg in september in New York and
said,
whilst the mic was on tomorrow,
looking at what can we do to stop people
writing anti-immigration things on
facebook,
and mark zuckerberg says,
we're working on it now.
Look,
I say This just as possible.
If you wanted to create a volcano in
europe,
the best way to do it will be to shut
down and stop legitimate public feeling
about things and to say that is no good
saying that you objected to the
migration on facebook.
It should be stopped.
That is the biggest way,
the fastest way to make sure the volcano
blows out of the site.
Yeah,
and it seems so obvious to me that this
is what the regressive left has done by
labeling everyone who doesn't agree with
them racist.
They've created a situation where good
intentioned people,
liberals are now finding themselves
agreeing on a lot of things with people
on the far right who they agree with.
nothing else on the danger,
I think.
I think the fact
is,
is that what the left has done in recent
years with the term racist has basically
ended up,
uh,
denuding the term of having any meaning
and,
or am or much meaning anyway,
because if,
if everybody can be called a racist at
some point,
and generally very often,
at least for various various grounds,
it means that you basically got no
terminology left when an actual racist
comes along and I can sort of sense the
people just,
I'm not going to end up not caring.
Uh,
in the future.
I've always said,
I want this solved.
I want this problem.
These sorts of problems dealt with in
order.
They're not dealt in the coming decades
by marine le pen and the,
your hydration elements in Austria,
but a few people listen.
Yeah,
I mean,
I totally hear that and that's why I'm
trying to bring this message that if we
have to get the left back,
otherwise we're just going to hand
everything over to the right,
which would be a disaster.
All right.
Let's talk a little more about the
middle east.
Let's talk about Israel.
Palestine.
We can probably knock that out and just
a few minutes and everyone will be
satisfied.
Right?
Um,
okay.
So buddy seconds,
thIrty seconds.
Let's do it.
So I thought maybe the best way to do
this because I do know how much you know
about history.
Um,
where should we start with this because
what I'm noticing lately is that,
you know,
as we're seeing the stabbings and the
shootings and all this,
the debate is rarely about what's
happening right now,
but now the debate is starting to be on
the partition plan.
Ah,
the british mandate.
Like now it's starting to be unfurled
and people don't understand history as
we alluded to earlier.
So where is a good place if we're going
to have a decent discussion and try to
get some common ground here,
where is a good place to start with the,
with the Israel palestine situation?
I think the only place you to start is
from where we are really,
and an acceptance that on the part of
people who are broadly anti as well and
acceptance by those people that Israel
exists and that it's not going anywhere.
You know,
I've,
I,
I've spent a lot of time there in the
surrounding areas and the west bank and
so on and spoken with a lot of
palestinian representatives and so on.
And one of the saddest things is when
you hear them talk about the occupation
and you discovered that talking about
the occupation from 1948 because then
you say,
you know what,
you're,
you're giving your future generations
know,
hope you're selling them a lie.
You're telling them that we'll get back
to tel aviv,
you know,
we'll get back to the whole of jerusalem
will get back heifer.
And so it's not going to happen is
they're a bit,
they're selling the young people a
crock.
And,
and I think it's a tragedy if it's,
if they accepted that Israel is not
going anywhere and Israel felt confident
enough that the palestinians accepted
that,
then the negotiations for the border
dispute,
uh,
frankly quite straightforward.
Um,
uh,
you can see,
you can,
you can see them on the ground.
You can see basically,
uh,
you know,
the israelis have one and basically when
the palestinians have one and you can
see that,
you know,
the,
the basis for what's often been called
the world's ugliest border.
Uh,
but,
you know,
you have to start from the premise,
let Israel is not going anywhere.
And,
and I think it is one of the most
striking things,
uh,
that in 2015,
so many debates on college campuses and
in the media and so on,
don't accept that fact.
And you know,
if we had a conversation about a
Pakistan and uh,
and we started by saying,
you know,
should Pakistan have been created or not
as a mistake?
And we wonder If we could rectify this
error.
You know,
people would say,
what are you talking about?
It's 20 slash 15.
Pakistan's got all sorts of problems we
need to talk about.
But uh,
why are we talking about this?
This is,
this is a problem from seven decades
ago.
you'd be a maniac.
But,
but,
but on Israel that's thought quite
normal.
Israel and Pakistan to the same age,
and these,
these crazy Israel obsessives uh,
uh,
keeP going back to the basis and they're
not going to win.
That's over.
That's done.
So what do you make of these people?
so because I see that,
I see very clearly,
I try to tweet as much stuff as I can
about coexistence.
I want there to be two states for two
people and understand that people can't
live in occupation.
And I want everyone to be treated with
dignity and have the right to self
determination and all that.
but I see nothing except on the,
on the left.
All I see is just this relentless
demonization of Israel.
No matter,
no matter what they do.
Look,
they left gaza.
There's not one jew and guys,
a hitler would love the place,
right?
Yeah.
No,
yeah,
you'd feel right at home in certain Way.
Is that.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but the problem is that by the way,
when you said tuesday,
the tuesday solution doesn't exist.
It's dead.
It's gone.
Uh,
the best you can hope for now as a three
state solution because it's in no one's
gift to unite the palestinian.
Right?
So I want to,
I wanted to ask you about that too
because it really is a three states.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know.
It'd be which you'd stopped using the
two to state idea.
Um,
but you then have to ask some serious
questions about the negotiating partners
on both sides.
Now people like to say here and again,
the clever thing to say is,
well,
you know,
six of one,
half a dozen of the other and so on.
It is simply not the case that the
israeli prime minister,
it Uses the rhetoric about the
palestinians like palestinian,
moderate,
so called moderate leader.
Mahmoud abbas is used in recent weeks
about the jews.
Uh,
you know,
mahmoud abbas was talking about the,
we,
we don't want the filthy feet of the
jews on our holy sites.
I mean this doesn't even get very much
coverage outside of the region.
And if benjamin netanyahu had made a
speech where he said,
we don't want any filthy muslim or arab
feet in our land,
I reckon that would've made the front
paGe of the New York times,
you know,
I think it would be being,
I think people would know about it,
does the most extraordinary incitement
now in the most extraordinary
denigration and,
and all that,
all that,
uh,
allegedly,
right thinking people in the west can do
is to say this is the man with whom you
must do piece because he's not as,
um,
I,
I think that the world should,
should concentrate less on the israeli
palestinian dispute.
You know,
I think it's,
um,
it's over egged.
It's got too much attention on it.
None of the attention helps.
there are intractable problems around
the world.
Uh,
the sovereign question,
the western starland question,
a cypress,
all sorts of ones.
And,
and actually a massive amounts of
international opprobrium and attention
do nothing to solve these conflicts.
Uh,
um,
you know,
we have seen in recent years the,
the,
the motif of our time fall apart in the
middle east.
And that was,
and it was said by everybody from light,
from right and left throughout my
upbringing.
At any rate,
if you could only unlock the problem of
the paleStinian israeli dispute,
the rest of the middle east will be
solved.
I heard this for years.
Uh,
you know,
some of the israeli palestinian border
dispute and the economy of Yemen will
boom and the iranians will see the point
of gay rights and the saudis will
understand,
you know,
the potential utility of women in this
society.
It was obviously nonsense then,
but we've seen it's nonsense in recent
years we've seen it because the middle
east has managed to fall apart with zero
israeli involvement.
YeAh.
So is that the bigger issue here?
Is that sort of,
that we're really talking about a three
day thing because gaza and the west bank
are totally separate ruled by different
people.
And there's no reason to think that if a
boss signed an agreement that hamas
would abide by it.
I mean,
in their,
uh,
you know,
their,
what do they call it,
their charter.
It says Kill all the jews.
So they're not going to suddenly change,
so they're not.
So that's the strange part as I see
people in the west saying,
well,
you know,
just make a solution,
make a magical solution,
and they'll stop wanting to kill you.
But it doesn't seem like there's a
connection for those people.
It's not about the middle east.
They've gfo never been there.
They don't,
they don't know anyone there.
Uh,
it's about them.
Goes back to that point I made the star.
It's about them.
Uh,
if,
if you say how concerned you are about
this situation,
you come across as virtuous and
knowledgeable cad.
It's way out,
right?
And yet there's one place in the middle
east that stands for their progressive
values
now and now they use the progressive
values against it.
Totally.
But if you highlight the fact that,
you know,
uh,
that in isRael,
gays have everyone in one and in every
other country in the region,
you get hanged people,
god said,
detail why you bother,
why,
why you pink washing,
why you doing this house for them and
you,
you're actually,
you know,
for me it's not a detail.
I mean,
I,
I mind whether I'm hanging with or not,
uh,
mind whether other gays are hanged on
our mind,
what their views are,
and a whole range of things in mind.
There's a difference between a society
in Israel is actually talking about what
you do about ivf rights for lesbian
couples and a few miles away,
uh,
lesbians,
lesbians don't get a look in on the ivf
treatment or anything else I mind about
that.
These are details,
but all of these things that used to be
the things we used to say,
well,
what we used to call me,
the things that matter are now a brushed
aside as being odd.
Don't you bore me with all that,
all that,
all those facts.
So you keep comIng up with.
Yeah.
All right,
well you gave me a great segue there
because I wanted to discuss one personal
thing with you because you're,
I personal.
You're going to get.
Well,
we'll see.
We'll see how far I can push it.
You're openly gay.
That phrase seems silly to me.
You're gay.
Um,
and I wonder if for you.
I'm gay also.
I don't know if you know that,
um,
or,
and it shouldn't matter in any context
of anything we're talking about here,
but I wonder for you,
how much of the principles that you're
talking about and wanting to help when
you talk about the lesbian that might
live in gaza under hamas or any of this
stuff,
you know,
the people being thrown off the roofs by
isis or women's rights here,
there,
how much of whAt you talk about and what
you care about,
do you think has been colored by the
fact that you and a lot of respects are
the other at the same time?
Yeah,
a bit.
I think it's easy to over again most of
my political ideas or not,
uh,
not based on I know who I am or,
or,
you know,
then I like to think they're not me
centric.
Um,
I didn't like in politics on me centric
because I'm something therefore I have
to,
I like to think I,
I try to use reason and go beyond
identity politics.
I suppose there was some things which
you notice some things which you might
notice first.
I do have a sort of view that when it
comes to radical islam,
of what we've seen in recent years,
a set of early warning sirens going off
basically around the world and some of
those early warning sirens are gay.
Um,
some of them,
I mean bruce banner,
for instance,
the gay writer in scandinavia who went
off as an early warning signal,
you know,
uh,
some of them are feminists,
some of them are,
um,
some of them are from our religious
dissidence or you know,
minorities within a minority.
And,
and of course some of jews.
And I,
I think in a way that's interesting
because as I said,
I do think it's a basis for my interest
or focus on these areas.
But I think it's true that the,
there's,
um,
there's a lovely phrase that the
composer benjamin britten volunteers,
and I'll let her to another composer.
He said that,
um,
the composers have one less layer of
skin than everyone else.
And I've often often thought that might
apply in some of these very programmatic
world events that were sort of starting
to go through at the moment,
is that there are a set of people who
feel it just a little bit before
everyone else.
And I think that's true of gay people.
A lot of gay people,
a lot of them have raised close to that
and don't care a lot or don't take
notice.
I think it's true of a lot of jews.
I think it's true of a lot of minorities
within islam who suffered,
um,
and,
and others.
So it's true that it might be a habit,
sort of early warning effect.
But apart from that,
I,
I like to think that my politics don't
come from any rabbit.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I think the same thing about myself
because I hate identity politics
obviously.
And yet I do.
I feel this kinship when I hear about
gay people being killed somewhere in the
middle east just for being who they are.
And then at the same time,
they're also,
when you repress all these people,
it's fertile ground for all of the awful
religious stuff to also take root.
So it's so multilayered.
Right?
But,
but,
you know,
I mean,
I do think that the,
I do think the big problem of our time
is the identity in,
in,
in the western side is,
is this,
is this basically self centered way of
looking into the world.
I haven't absolute bugbear,
which is people who start Questions by
saying,
speaking as a and then say,
you know,
speaking as a gay man or whatever.
I mean,
you,
you do it if you know it's going to wind
the hell out of someone I suppose.
But I don't like that.
I don't like it when people start off as
either speaking as a woman of puerto
rican descent or anything.
I get it again,
you know,
if your point is good,
it'll be valid,
whoever's saying it.
Um,
but unfortunately,
uh,
um,
I mean the whole,
the,
the amazing thing.
We're seeing a moment of that sort of
breakdown.
I think of identity politics.
It's having a breakdown.
I at the moment and that partly is it is
coming because it was always going to
collapse under the,
the way to its own absurdities and the
only answer to that when you sift
through the rubble of that strange
spasmic collike movement in recent years
and the only way out of it will be
through reason and,
and,
and using rationalism and,
and not trying to work out what we think
about the world from what is most
convenient for me because I may,
but uh,
but trying to work things out on
principles and there's quite a lot of
work to do.
Right?
Which is so crazy because when you think
about it now I've sat here with you for
probably about 50 minutes or so.
I got no indication that you Were racist
or a xenophobe or any of the other
things that people might say about you.
I only got an indication that you want
to deal with the realities as they are
not sort of as you want them to be.
A.
So my last question for ya,
and I barely looked at my notes because
we could do this for hours and I hope
next time you're in town,
we'll,
we'll do it in person.
But my last question is gimme gimme some
hope.
What can we,
what can we take at this interesting
moment as you said,
you see identity politics crumbling.
I see the same thing.
What can we as a secular people as,
as atheists,
as people that care about gay people,
all of that stuff.
WhaT can we take from this sort of
precarious moment where at and,
and sort of feel good for,
for the future.
Good luck.
I think optimism is overrated.
I don't like the idea.
One has to be optimistic or pessimistic
or anything.
I wouldn't have to sort of look at
things as they are.
And sometimes you might wake up in the
morning feeling optimistic and you might
lose it by lunchtime.
Sometimes you might go out in the
evening feeling pessimistic and come
home optimistic.
Who knows?
These are things that come and go.
Um,
I,
I think there's a lot that one can be
optimistic about.
Um,
you know,
I,
I do have a view that I'm trying to
finish a book about this at the moment.
I do have a view that I'm,
one of the things that multimedia and
social media things has done and is
doing at the moment is,
is it going to create a reform within
islam or change within islam because
what people are having to face up to is
now coming to them at a speed which in,
for instance in christianity took a
couple of centuries to drift down from
learning institutions in Germany,
for instance,
down to the person on the street,
um,
that took a couple of centuries in the
past.
And now it's happening with unbelievable
speed.
I think it's going to be a,
this is the bad news,
quite bloody and a very bad for a
period.
Um,
but after that it means that we'll be
out of it within a fairly short space of
time.
Um,
as for other things,
I mean,
you know,
people,
people's access to ideas and things,
you know,
obviously we hear a lot about all of the
craziness that goes on the web and
elsewhere,
but people's access to ideas now,
it's never been better.
Um,
and people,
people geT to find out the good things
as well.
you know,
what,
you can open your computer in the
morning and read about a train crash
somewhere that you've never heard of
until that day.
And you can feel sad for a bit and
people do and people feel overwhelmed
with the amount of information,
the,
well,
the amount of negative things.
But,
uh,
I,
I think in middle of that as well,
you know,
you have to have a life and you have to
try to think your way through the things
that are going on.
And I,
I think the,
the most important thing is the appeal
for something beyond a,
a utopia.
Something other than utopia.
Religions and others constantly told
people how to get utopia in the
afterlife when this life,
most political movements promise people
utopia.
Utopia is called utopia for a reason.
It's no place it doesn't exist,
it never did.
It never will,
but in the meantime,
it's a much better thing to think of how
You can make the lives of the people
around you better and how you can
broadly have a good influence in the
world at the time you've gone,
but not to think that your role is to
make everything else better for everyone
else in the world when you come to even
help mom with the dishes unit and and,
and,
but as I say,
I mean,
the only thing I can think of that
that's positive is the fact that all
this is happening so fast now that just
as things can screw up at an amazing
speed,
it's possible.
It is possible that they can also be
sold at an amazing speed,
but that won't bring us nirvana.
It just is an appeal that,
that will have to keep on paying
attention.
I have to keep on concentrating and
reading and thinking about these things.
All right.
I actually,
I think that was pretty lofty right
there.
It was a pleasure chatting with you and
I fully get why so many people wanted
this to happen.
By the way,
I should mention that your ebook,
islam ophelia,
isn't available online anymore.
Uh,
but you're,
you're rolling it into a new book that
you're working on right now.
Right.
I'm very proud is affiliate with an
ebook I wrote a quite swiftly a couple
years ago and,
uh,
I was very proud of the fact we
immediately beat the chron and the best
seller lists on amazon,
uh,
around the globe.
And I thought,
well,
I'm onto Something here.
It's true.
It's true that mohammed had a head
start.
But anyhow,
I'm finishing a book at the moment that
incorporates islam affiliate,
which is a word I wish I could encourage
people to,
to use more.
All right,
well,
we'll see if it picks up for more info
on the work that douglas is doing.
You guys can check out Henry Jackson
society.org
and douglas.
He was,
it was an absolute pleasure.
So thanks.
Thanks a lot for doing this.
Yeah.